so
2023 that was uh a thing that happened
as I reflect on the year here are some
of the things that jump out to me the
most about
[Music]
it Drex here from Drex Factor po sharing
with you the love of pois spinning and
flow Arts to benefit your body and brain
and today I'm going to count down 10 of
the things that I think think I'm going
to remember most about 2023 but before
we dive in I just want to give a quick
shout out to the Friends of the channel
big thanks to dark monk fire Mecca flow
fests flow toys juggling calling pyroar
light toys spinballs and Ultra poy for
helping to make the videos on this
channel possible you can learn more
about all these awesome companies and
the work that they're doing to support
flow artists like yourself by checking
out the links down in the description of
this video and special thanks to the
non- bus friend of the channel Becca
Becken thank you so very much for
supporting my channel my work and my
mission so I had such high hopes going
into 2023 I had this big old road map
laid out for how I was going to approach
creating content I had big ideas for
things that I could do to expand my
channel and expand my brand and almost
everything either just like blew up on
the Launchpad or just simply didn't
connect with people
but that's not to say that there weren't
also highs to this year and as I'm
sitting here at the end of the year kind
of reflecting on everything that's come
before I wanted to share with Y all some
of the things that I think really stuck
out about this year and that I think
that I'm going to look back on this year
as being an inflection point around so
I'm going to give you 10 specific things
five of which are kind of global and
five of which are a little bit more
personal or at least more localized to
the flow Arts Community number one it
has to be said that 2023 was a year of
massive conflicts in the world between a
second year of war in Ukraine and the
invasion of Gaza it really seems like a
lot of the world order is just becoming
incredibly destabilized to say nothing
of tensions around China and Taiwan it's
going to be a big question in the coming
years what the world's going to wind up
looking like and I think that all of us
are really really nervous watching it
but the news wasn't all bad in fact I
think that this was a pretty great year
for a lot of different forms of
entertainment Chief among which is uh as
Beyonce said in the song who runs the
world girls Taylor Swift and Beyonce
have been out there redefining what the
diva is in the modern era between the
two of them creating two of the most
massive tours that have ever happened in
human history and Beyonce of course
becoming the most decorated Grammy
nominee in history too the AOS tour in
particular really felt like not just a
concert but an event I've had people on
my feed talking about it for months and
uh I think it's pretty cool that uh Miss
Tay has that kind of connection with her
fans well done there and of course we
had Barbie Heimer this year which as
interesting as it was to have those two
confluences of Pop Culture threads
collide with each other I saw both
movies and quite frankly both of them
were really good I enjoyed them both
quite a bit I think I'd have to give a
slight Edge to Barbie in a head-to-head
competition but the fact that we got
both of them on the same day is kind of
an embarrassment of riches kind of dug
the movies this year I remember the the
same time last year when chat GPT came
out and became a really big deal and
that was when it became clear to me that
AI was not just here to stay but it was
going to have a massive impact on the
world since then I think that it has
only become something that is becoming
ever more present in all of our
attentions as we think about what
happens with the future and as we think
about how generative AI is going to have
an impact in how we consume media and
create it Bill Gates posted a threads a
couple days ago saying that he thinks
it's maybe 18 to 24 months before
generative AI becomes omnipresent in our
lives and deeply integrated into a lot
of the processes around us I actually
don't think it's going to take that long
personally but uh we'll have to see how
it shakes out maybe 2024 will be even
more of an inflection year also kind of
related but I've seen several articles
now talking about something that I
mentioned in my 10 predictions for the
future of the flow Arts video namely the
death of social media
I don't think that social media will
ever go completely away but I do think
that we're watching a steady decline of
it right now which is going to be really
interesting Twitter is definitely in the
process of kind of collapsing under its
own weight and Tik Tok went from the
most visited website on the planet to
not even making it into the top 10 this
year it really seems like we might be at
an inflection point where people want
different sorts of connections online
I've heard a lot about people switching
to messaging apps or using Discord and
quite frankly I think that those things
are going to kind of have their own
unique lifespan and their own unique
kind of trajectory both as tools where
the initial run of it is going to seem
very authentic and exciting and then
over time there's going to be a lot of
noise and it's going to get harder and
harder to sort the signal from it we'll
have to see all right so those are the
things in the global sense now how about
in the personal sense so have this awful
suspicion and I really really hope I'm
wrong about this that 2023 might also
Mark an inflection year where what we
think of as the flow Arts kind of either
met its end or began its transition to
the end specifically I see a lot of
people online kind of disowning the
title flow artist and associating the
term flow Arts with the most negative
parts of the community which you know I
kind of get it there have been a lot of
things that I've been really upset with
in the community the past few years as
well and there's only a certain amount
that people may want to stick around and
try and fight and turn the tide of
things before they decide that it's just
time to pick up and move on to greener
pastures believe me I get it we'll have
to see if this is a thing that is a
spark in the pan or whether indeed we
can turn the tide here but this year
more than any other year I can remember
I have definitely seen people distancing
themselves from that title in quantities
that I was not anticipating and kind of
further along that track this has
without peer been the most difficult
year that I have personally had in
interacting with the flowarts
community earlier in the year there was
a person online who started stalking me
and specifically did so to engage in
online
harassment it was terrifying it was
incredibly difficult to get through and
it made it all the worse when a couple
months later uh I got cancelled for a
post that I made on threads which
between these two
incidents I think I have felt more alone
in this community than I ever have
before and that's really really sucked
um not the least of which because I've
invested so much of myself into it over
the
years I'm not sure where I'm going with
that and there might be more that I have
to say about one or both incidents in
the future but uh today is not that day
but once again the news isn't all bad
and one of those bright spots in this
year for me was committing myself to
exploring po dance in a more consistent
fashion and that led to not only me
writing when one of my favorite po dance
pieces that I've ever done but also
making it a regular practice to write
choreography every week and going into
the dance studio and busting out a
variety of different little phrases that
range from being kind of sad to being
really sassy and even really sexy was a
highlight of every week for me doing
that brought me so much joy this year
even and especially sometimes when
people gave me very very negative
feedback for doing so and of course 2023
saw the meteoric rise of a brand new po
star Boris Mi took to the scene and
captured hearts and Minds in a way that
I have not seen since John Alvarez burst
onto the scene roughly a decade ago it's
both kind of cool to watch because again
I can't remember the last time anybody
burst onto the scene and was that
universally loved and also at the same
time a little alarming because I
remember how things went with John so
here's hoping that history does not
repeat itself and finally on a very
personal note I think that this was a
year that I felt more connected with my
family's past and history than I ever
have before going to Northwest flow Fest
also gave me an opportunity to visit the
national Nordic Museum and connect with
a variety of artifacts that come from
places in Finland that I have only ever
heard of where our an ancestors came
from and gave me a ability to connect
with some of my SII Heritage plus which
I went back and visited the family farm
in Michigan where we settled after we
came to this country for the first time
in 5 years since uh just after my
grandmother passed away it was good
being back on the farm and talking to my
relatives about their experiences
growing up on it and how we became who
we are today it's very very grounding
and I really
appreciated getting to explore this side
of my world this year in a way that I
hadn't before it meant a lot now there
are definitely some other things that
stuck out in this year and some things
that are too personal to share but I
figure that this is at least a good
place to start for right now so what
about you what are you going to remember
about 2023 leave me a comment and let me
know be sure to like share and subscribe
so other people can find this video and
of course help my channel
grow this video would not be possible
without my awesome supporters on patreon
in particular I'd love to give a shout
out to my flow patrons who are listed on
screen right now if you'd love to get
your name in this list there's an easy
way to do that you can go ahead and sign
up at my patreon doing so helps me keep
on making videos like this one and
videos that I put more thought into as
well if you'd like to sign up to support
my work you can do so by heading on over
to
patreon.com director po there's a whole
host of awesome rewards that you can
sign up for do check that out please and
thank you cool so I hope you've enjoyed
going on a short walk with me as I
reflect on the year um I'm kind of
curious what are your hopes and dreams
for
2024 and what do you think will be the
inflection points that we'll remember in
the coming year goodness predicting the
future uh in the meantime thanks for
watching make sure to get and flow today
and I'll see you with a new video real
soon take care now peace